Island is at a crossroads on the 25th of
May the Irish people will decide whether
to repeal the eighth amendment and end a
constitutional ban on abortion being the
eighth would mean that a compassionate
caring country gets to reveal its true
colors finally the reality is the tens
and thousands of lives will be lost each
and every year women could who need
abortions could have them here in
Ireland they could be safe and well we
are changing a law in Ireland that has
protected mothers and babies
your first minute of that scanner your
first second was was joy like you know
he's you see the little blob and you
hear the heartbeat you know it's there
and then and then I just knew I knew and
she was quiet when she said nothing and
when she said it she is your husband
here I just thought this isn't good news
last year Amy and Connor were expecting
their second child but at the 12-week
scan their unborn baby Nico was
diagnosed with a fatal condition called
anencephaly which affects the baby's
brain and skull she said that it was
likely the baby would pass away in utero
and that some babies then do go full
term and if they do go full term and you
give birth they're likely to die while
you're giving birth and and that if the
baby didn't die well he would give birth
it was gonna be a few minutes maybe an
hour or two and and I started to think
at that stage that that was not a kind
way for a baby to die and I was thinking
about myself and having to spend the
next six months pregnant with people
asking me how far along I was before all
this happened I I would have I would
have known that abortion was illegal
here that in in most cases but I thought
I thought in a case where it was this
severe where there really wasn't a brain
where a baby was missing most of its
brain and where the amniotic fluid would
be wearing the brain down until until
she died I really thought they'd they
could help more I was angry but I didn't
know where to target it because even you
know in Ireland the Irish doctors and
nurses there they're totally hums from
where the law if they wanted even if
they wanted to help helping us comes
with a 14 year jail sentence which is
crazy why should a medical issue come
with essentially a jail sentence hanging
over us
to understand islands of bortion laws
you have to go back to 1983 when the
country voted to insert a pro-life
amendment into its constitution those
involved in the campaign for women's
right to choose an abortion remember it
is hugely divisive it's completely
different now from what it was in 83 and
you know I got horrible things
Nosa stuck on my car phone calls in the
middle of the night people reciting the
rosary than the phone three decades
later an island is still divided about
what kind of country it wants to be
[Music]
the no side says the rights of the
unborn must be protected they're
travelling the country trying to reach a
large swathe of undecided voters save
the 8th campaign of icky wolves baby was
diagnosed with a rare genetic disorder
Edwards syndrome at 23 weeks I think he
knew by my face this abortion would not
be an option for us wouldn't be in our
race to abort her she was unique and she
was adult and she was value to us Vickie
continued with her pregnancy but her
baby died at 32 weeks he hadn't died at
home surrounded by her family and with
love and with care and most of all with
dignity and I take a massive comfort in
that that she died on her terms
we've talked about your your really
difficult choice that you made do you
feel comfortable in making that choice
for other women rather than letting them
make that choice for themselves well we
have to look at what the choice entails
what are we saying we have the choice to
do we're looking to have the choice to
end a unique human life and
I don't think that choice is a
reasonable choice bottom line on it
would be that I am extremely pro-life
and I think life should be protected
there very good thing to leave to leave
with the undecided in Dublin a repeal
stronghold the yes site are taking
nothing for granted if they win the vote
the government will introduce new laws
allowing unrestricted access to
abortions up to 12 weeks that makes a
lot of people uncomfortable so the focus
on the doorstep is on the more tragic
stories we're going to see more cases of
women dying because of the area we're
going to see more gross gross injustice
we're going to see people who suffer a
fatal fetal anomaly diagnosis we're
going to have to travel continue to
travel so I think I think I hope that
they will side with the ESA up to 9
Irish women a day travel overseas for an
abortion and this campaign has left many
of them reliving that journey once again
I booked the flights I booked the hotel
and we managed to find a babysitter for
our son because we needed to go
overnight um and and we flew as fluid on
her ryanair flight with stag parties and
hen parties and and other other women as
well you know we were there and we were
like I wonder is there anyone else on
the plane and sure enough when we got to
the clinic because I guess or other
people I'm Ida surgical abortion so I
was put under and then I gave Snickers
remains in a box when we left and we
went to an airport hotel and you were
starving we hadn't eaten because it was
a surgical procedure I hadn't eaten a
long time and and so Connor was like we
were there with Nico and Connor me
like Oh we'll have to go get dinner and
I was like we can't leave Nikko here and
so you went and got a plate of food back
and then got on the plane then the next
day that was I mean I think that was one
of the lowest point we had to pass
Niko's remains through the x-ray machine
and walked through security and you
turned to me and said what what if they
ask us to open the box and I just said
they won't they know but I didn't know I
didn't know at the time
the referendum has exposed divisions
between cities and rural towns between
young and older voters it's another step
in Islands journey to becoming a more
secular state for you this error and
we're gonna be talking to dr. Ayman
McGuinness we'll be asking him the
question on whether the eighth amendment
puts women's health at risk that's all
coming up in this era right now the
Christian radio stations Spirit FM
presenter Wendy grace insists the battle
over abortion is not about religion for
me
abortion is nothing to do with faith to
be honest with you I think it's a human
rights issue for all faiths and on I
don't think you have to be of any
particular faith to say it's wrong to
end another human life the Catholic
Church is not as powerful as it once was
here but it still has a strong presence
and conversations with some voters in
rural towns are telling the 10
commandments as well I mean thou shalt
not kill your no no they have no rights
to little babies it's against the laws
of God and nature they have no right
do not get pregnant in the first place
do not have sex then you won't get
pregnant actress Tara Flynn says Ireland
has a problem with shame she told her
abortion story at a music festival in
2015 because she wanted to end the
stigma but people stood up right there
in that moment until their stories
and that's when I realized that the
warmth out there for people who have
already traveled people have traveled
with them people are keeping secrets in
this country happened for a very long
time it has been Catholic but there's
been a Dogma here that has entered our
laws entered our judgement of people's
situations be it their sexuality be it
their you know their their gender so I
think we I think it's time to examine
that past other women's stories line the
walls of this campaign shop but still
very few women want to speak publicly
about their experiences
so we got home and I suppose it was
again one of those situations where
there was no guidance from anyone no one
told us what do you do when you get back
and we knew enough to ring the the
hospital here - about my mental health
physical health but we had Nico's
remains and so we put Nico's remains in
our freezer I started looking into what
our options were we looked into funerals
and cremations but nothing nothing
seemed to suit our situation you know we
we had a tiny cardboard box and we
didn't really know what to do and in the
end and we felt that you know we didn't
really have to follow anyone's rules
anymore we didn't really get any support
so we could make our own rules so we got
in a car one day and we we drove down
the country to a place we we really
liked somewhere peaceful and we buried
Nico's remains and we went to the family
we hugged quite a bit and we said
goodbye for women like Aimee these
images can be deeply upsetting and a
source of tension between the two sides
locked in rouse over whether these
posters are misleading and in poor taste
Ireland's changed dramatically over the
past three decades voting for divorce
supporting gay marriage but when it
comes to the matter of abortion people
hold deep rooted beliefs and everyone
I've spoken to here tells me that this
is a difficult conversation and this is
proven to be a closely fought campaign
whatever the polls suggest and when it's
all over somehow people here have got to
try to come back together
this is an emotive issue which has split
families and friends I saw his godmother
and I actually had a huge fund out we
have a spoke in a year because she's a
nurse and she's what yes and I'm a vote
no and like is lychee its it has
actually divided looks like weird it's
not speaking at all both sides feel
passionately that this vote is about
fighting for the type of island that
they want to live in and both sides
viral to fight on it wouldn't end
because this really matters on an
everyday basis just so many people - so
many women in this country these people
that are looking for appeal I don't see
them with any support groups for this
they just want abortion and then they
want to walk away whatever the result
this vote will be a significant
milestone in islands of bortion wars as
for a lasting peace that still feels a
long way off